they managed to get this
and we are so grateful from allah about
us
for giving for showering his mercy
on our nation
islamic
from now on the war has finished so we
are not at
being forgiven
so
amnesty has been announced
taliban do not have any enemies against
anyone
all hostilities have been finished
we are at this historic moment that we
are
system our leaders are instead stops in
order how to form this government
we are looking to form a government
which is actually acceptable to whole
people including
or came under um control of the our
mujahideen
there were some complications
there were some some people some
insurgents they want to take advantage
of the situation
and take advantage of the situation
and then
therefore the majority
sense that it is sensible to enter the
city and take the control of
the security is firm and has been
and kind of insurgencies
after they
captured the whole village the whole
country all other provinces they should
come and stand
by by the door of kabul
they should they should not enter
because we didn't want to bring war
in kabul
that is our aim that we finish
discussion we sort out our issues and
then slowly enter kabul in a peaceful
manner unfortunately
the previous government
the security officers or the security
officials from the previous government
who were supposed to keep the security
they left their position and vacate
their
buildings
during the last
couple of days some insurgents some
thieves some pets they wanted to
loot and some areas
[Music]
but we
we can ensure
is
they should respect our islamic law
that's not islamic principles
and it is because we have given love
we lost loss of life
in this way and this is our right and
this
as we respect them
we expect respect from them as well
the women's issue is a very important
issue
we gave rise to all women's according to
islamic principles
right according to
islamic values what allah has
as before within the islamic principles
[Music]
or have any concerns about women's
rights
we assure them
that they should not have any islamic
problems they should not have any
concerns
our women would like to have their own
their life and carry their life
according to islamic principles
when afghanistan is getting out of war
situation
afghanistan
situation will also improve
the whole
please
foreign
that is against
our
we do not want any kind of
discrimination
in any any kind of discrimination
either linguistic discrimination ethnic
discrimination or any religious
discrimination so we want you to be
impatient
after a very long journey i didn't want
to keep you waiting but now
one by one delhi will be
so everybody has
a chance to ask one question so so
everybody's question will be
answered i want to talk to you about
women's rights and
girls who still go to school
what assurances can you give to women
and girls that their rights will be
protected
[Music]
or other activities because women
are a key part of society
and uh
we are guaranteeing all their rights
within the limits of islam
mr mujered earpanel abc news from
america um can i ask you
what guarantees can you give to the
afghans who fought with the americans
the interpreters
what guarantees will you give to the
afghans who are now hiding at home who
want to leave the country who the
americans will transform
i'm sorry one one one this is very
important because there's a man who's
being held hostage by the taliban
his name is
and on behalf of his parents they've
asked me to ask you whether you will now
commit to release
foreign
[Music]
fellow afghans
that who work
for the
foreigners or for the government
they are
being forgiven they come under our
amnesty
they do not have to leave and you go to
anywhere or leave
and ask them why they have done
of the hostage
uh i think this is an issue from very
previous years which i have no
information at the moment
[Music]
that we are assuring the safety of all
those who have worked with the united
states and allied forces
whether as interpreters or any other
field that they've worked with them
as for their talents and their skills
we do not want them to leave the country
we want them to serve their own homeland
as for the contractor that was perhaps
he's gone missing
as reported by the media
we do not have any information about him
at the moment
um
[Music]
have nothing to do with them
we have given amnesty to thousands of
soldiers
who fought against us
to return home nobody will pursue them
nobody come after them
they should be confident
there's no threat against them
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and that is the base for this safety and
security in afghanistan
and i i again repeat from a to that
everybody
comes under amnesty
we have not done anything intentionally
against anyone
that happened which was
a side effect of the war
but it was not intentional
so we are fighting
i have been hurt my family
that is very disappointing but it was
not intentional
you know that war
would not come without casualty
destruction
as is
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
as you know when the situation in the
city has changed those people have gone
out there was a kind of
some insurgents want to take advantage
of the situation
our
forces
had to come into kabul in order to take
control of the situation
and that's why it is militarized at the
moment
um